given that these beings are said to be
able to work through cognitive
manipulation and that level of
advancement
um how can we be sure that what we're
presented by them is real that they
don't have ulterior motives and just to
add on to that do you think that all of
the others are benevolent so that
there's a range
um and just because we're touched on and
see five things here I just wanted to
ask if you think there'll ever be a
chance for a ce5 peer review
um
well I mean people can review what we
have done and what we put out already
um what I think in terms of your other
question is if the the people who are
really addicted to the idea that there
is the whole you know cowboys and
Indians uh good name bad aliens they
don't seem to understand
that what part of that assessment is
coming from staged events that are
deceptive indication and warnings or
false flag
um and I think it's a very
simple to slip into this because humans
always like to have that drama of US
versus them I mean look at how divided
our country is politically that is
something that people feed on that so
how much of that is sort of in
acculturation and a sort of a
brainwashing
and how much of it is objectively real
now having done thousands of hours with
thousands of people doing ce5 all over
the world and adding all kinds of
contact experiences I see no evidence
that any of them are hostile or
malevolent in any way shape or form all
the things that have happened that have
been disturbing in that way have been
man-made copycat you know sort of
CopyCat alien stuff so my objective
analysis of it is I don't I don't see
that that's the case another sort of
intellectual analysis of it and that's
just empirical The Experience we've had
so you know a lot of people sit in their
their houses Googling the internet and
they think they know what they're doing
but they never go out and try to make
contact or observe something in real
time
um but so in doing that now for decades
I don't see any evidence of any of them
are hostile I do think that there have
been a number of staged events that
would make people conclude that they
were uh like the terrible burn victims
and the cash Landrum case which was our
covert Air Force operations out of
Nellis flying and extraterrestrial
vehicle we had captured and they put a
nuclear a a reactor on it because they
couldn't quite figure out the energy
generating part of it and it was being
flown and it malfunctioned and
radioactive junk was failing on on Betty
cash and Landrum and they were
hospitalized and that whole area the
road had to be dug up twice to get rid
of all the radioactivity that was there
but that was a human mishap of a test
flight of an extra vehicle but they were
happy for the media and the public to
say that aliens are poisoning us with
radioactive you see what I'm saying so
it was monkeys in the microwave it's not
extraterrestrials yeah and so this is
one of the real problems is that you
have to have you know I tend to take a
very
um skeptical view of a facile that's
sort of superficial analysis of that
until you can get to the root
information from the people who were
there what actually happened here
um and I I think there are many cases
like that so things that have led to
these Grand conspiracy theories
um and fear-mongering uh I think so many
of them are staged or misperceptions of
human events and so I think we have to
be before we start jumping into the
Will Smith and Independence Day let's
kick alien butt category I think we need
to you know be a little more rational
and deliberative and this is why I don't
see any evidence that there is a hostile
or malevolent extraterrestrial group out
there I think there are some rather
trouble some interdimensional beings
you know this is get you get to some of
these people who work in these spooky
programs that are doing uh Satan worship
and devil worship and all kinds of scary
stuff